all right Bruce I need you to listen
very carefully everyone keeps talking
about it Illuminati 666 and how all the
celebrities have gone big because of it
but the real answer is out there and
it's not beautiful I don't know how to
tell you this but potato people are real
don't laugh don't don't
potato people are real damnit I have
evidence let's begin with our beloved
our ever so gracious Cara Delevingne is
near yes I didn't believe it either
first but potato peoples are real damnit
exhibit a you see this potato just look
they look nothing alike am i right but
look closer close it's closer
is it starting to make sense yet have
you opened your eyes yet how can mirrors
be real if Cara Delevingne isn't real
the evidence is clear you still think
I'm crazy they know I'm on to them
they've been spying on me how could we
have been so blind she starting the
movie Paper Towns but that's not the
real movie it was called potato
now look closely our an ed sheeran not
thick not his beautiful ice or is hobbit
nose there yes yes assume it doesn't say
hi
the answer may shock you yes truth hurts
ed sheeran is a potato honestly like how
did we miss that one it clearly looks
like a potato we probably should have
seen that one coming shouldn't we yeah
Oh God it's a 95% match of God Oh God oh
why your ginger freckles I loved you you
were like a father to me ed you were
like a father to me they're not just in
our entertainment industry they're
slowly creeping in on yes you guessed it
our politics it's clearly a potato just
look just look at him if someone asked
me what is a potato that tries to grow
hair and become a president candidate
look like yeah well you're looking at it
the hair was a giant red flag that just
went right by us look at him it's trying
to hide his potato nests
oh god that looks creepy we're scanning
scanning for potatoes god please not
Trump anyone but Trump oh my god
he's there's no potatoes detected okay I
see I see I see now he's he's just bald
he's just bald he's just trying to cover
up that he's bald
okay I'll thank God but now no no no no
we got multiple potatoes detected okay
not not five sauce is there a difference
I can hardly tell that difference five
sauce
more like five potatoes
wait
oh god no please anyone but ed Garrett
of God he's not a potato it's not a
potato
he's a pope ugh tato
they're coming for me all right Rose I
need you to spread the word about all
these celebrity singers and politicians
send these pictures spread them out let
the word know that the pug people are
real hash tag club patitos [ __ ] it needs
a better name all right I gotta go
before they come I don't think I'll see
you in another video this is the end of
Buddha pie final brofist signing off